نعم انا الان في همم الموقع الذي تعرض
للهجوم الامس همم امام المركز الثقافي
الكردي احمد كايا وهو يقع هنا المنافذ
العمليه تمكن من الوصول الى هذا المركز
وصعد على الدرج واستهدف الاشخاص الذين
اطلق النار عليهم في جديد المعلومات كما
ذكرت انت انه ابلغ الشرطه بان دوافعه كانت
عنصريه لكن ايضا هناك تسريبات جديده همم
تصدر الان على وسائل الاعلام فرنسيه تقول
انه اعترف للشرطه بان همم انه نفذ هذا
العمل استهدافا للاكراد في فرنسا اذا هذه
هي اخر المعلومات التي صدرت عن الجاني وهو
ما يزال » لكن لم تصدر حتى الان همم من
قبل الشرطه الفرنسيه اي بيانات او اي
تصريحات رسميه تشير الى معترفه همم طبعا
امس سقط ثلاثه همم قتله كلهم همم
باستمرار احدهم تسمى سيده تسمى ايمينيكارا
وتلقب بي ايفين هي مقاتله كرديه سابقه
اصيبت خلال المعارك ضد تنظيم داعش في شمال
سوريا ونقلت الى فرنسا لتلقي العلاج ايضا
من بين القتل كان مغني كردي واسمه ميربير
وهو معروف بمعرضته للرئيسه التركي كان
ملاحق من قبل تركيا ومحكوم عليه بالسجن
ولجا الى فرنسا قتل هذا المغني في مطعم
هذا الذين الذي ترونه الان على الشاشه
مقابل هذا المركز كان ياكل في هذا المطعم
وتوجه اليه القادم وتمكن من قتل هذه
المقاطع
الذي امامه الان هل هو تجمع احتجاججي ومن
يقف وراءها طبيعته ما هي اهداف ايضا
الجاليه الكرديه تتجمع الان امام المركز
الثقافي الكردي احمد كيا همم
لتحضيرا لتظاهر الضخمه التي سوف تنطلق بعد
ساعه من الان في ساحه الجمهوريه في قلب
العاصمه باريس هذه او هذه الحشود بدات
الان بالتحرك نحو الساحه التي تبعد اا
تقريبا حوالي كيلو متر واحد من هنا حيث
يقع المركز الذي يستهدف امس التظاهره من
الموت من المتوقع ان تكون حاشده جدا سوف
تشارك فيها الجاليه الكرديه في فرنسا
بالاضافه الى احزاب سياسيه فرنسيه او
بعضها على الاقل همم علمنا ان حزب فرنسا
غير الخاضعه بقياده الرئيس
يكون على راس هذه التظاهرات ايضا يشارك
فيها اليوم